[Music]
on this Saturday night here comes the
haze unhealthy smoke blanketing large
swaths of Canada it takes toll on your
breathing and it takes toll on your on
your sleepiness the off the charts
wildfires flooding and record-breaking
heat targeting the country there's no
one that's going to not be touched
Winnipeg standoff despite a cold ruling
why some indigenous protesters are
staying put the request is if you can
play with the order and then you move to
the side of the road
hugs for Heroes just glad to be alive a
patient reunited with the paramedics who
saved his life and a fairy tale finish
at Wimbledon meet the first unseated
female champion who just made history
global national with baronessor
I think gray Paul Smothers the city of
Quinnell in central BC leaving 25 000
people without fresh air to breathe in
Edmonton the smoke blocks out the sun
and the air quality is rated at 10 plus
posing a very high risk to People's
Health
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us millions of people across
most of western Canada are being advised
to keep their windows and doors shut and
to limit any time Outdoors Environment
Canada has issued air quality advisories
from Central British Columbia to
Southeastern Saskatchewan including all
of Alberta smoke from fires in western
Canada is spreading as far as the Great
Lakes with the highest concentrations
covering thousands of square kilometers
stretching from North Central BC all the
way to the Arctic
the military is mobilizing to help the
fight against the fires that have
already burned more than 12 thousand
square kilometers of forest in British
Columbia firefighters are battling more
than 500 fires across the west and as
Megan King reports in our top story
tonight there's no relief in sight
already deemed the worst Wildfire season
on record across Canada the epicenter
has shifted to British Columbia more
than half the country's active fires are
now in BC the majority caused by
lightning strikes when these kinds of
fires happen when their lightning
strikes like this it's often a storm
that comes in and produces multiple
fires simultaneously and that can be
problematic because it makes the
response a little bit more complex to
Aid in firefighting efforts emergency
preparedness Minister Bill Blair
approved a request for federal
assistance Friday night which will see
military mobilization to BC we're still
really early in the fire season
and I worry about you know First
Responders
um our firefighters just becoming
incredibly exhausted and so when federal
assistance like this comes in it's it's
a welcome thing in in my opinion because
it just gives an opportunity for
firefighters to have a break Blair's
announcement comes just after a 19 year
old firefighter was killed by a fallen
tree while battling a wildfire new
Revelstoke BC the whole Community is
reeling our province
is a mourning for her death we're all
still in shock because we can't really
imagine someone that nice
and just amazing human being leaving all
of a sudden in such a really terrible
way but also Really Brave fueling the
fires there's a concerning level of
drought in the region with no
significant precipitation expected until
we get actual good precipitation for a
long period of time that's what's really
going to make a big difference and that
impacts air quality Environment Canada
rates areas of Alberta British Columbia
and Saskatchewan as high risk with the
smoke bringing health concerns it takes
a toll on your breathing and it takes a
toll on your on your sleepiness and your
tiredness still early into the Wildfire
season there's no respite from the smoke
and the fires anytime soon
Megan King Global News
it's not fire but flooding causing
issues for residents around Montreal
people are still cleaning up after a
powerful storm swept through the region
this week
we have to like improvise since there's
no electronics that kids are days use
them a lot so we have to go outside and
play with friends
more than twenty thousand homes woke up
without power this morning almost 800
Hydro Quebec staff work to restore
service at the height of Thursday's
storm more than 392 thousand customers
were without power
and around the world it is extreme heat
that continues to be the story for
hundreds of millions of people here at
home parts of the Northwest Territories
Labrador and Newfoundland are under heat
warnings and they're not alone
thermometers in North America Europe
Africa and even parts of Asia are
hitting record-breaking temperatures
this weekend several meteorological
agencies are urging people to stay cool
and indoors if possible with the
sweltering heat expected to linger into
next week in many places
in the United States the Southwest is
bearing the brunt of this latest heat
Dome with temperatures in Phoenix
expected to remain over 43 degrees for a
50th straight day the national weather
service has placed more than 110 million
people under heat advisories with
warnings stretching from Florida to
California and up into Washington State
officials are urging Americans not to
underestimate the impact of what they're
calling an extremely dangerous Heat Wave
mixed with smoke from our wildfires in
some states
in Europe hundreds have been forced to
evacuate from the Spanish island of La
Palma as the extreme heat fuels a
fast-moving Wildfire near
record-breaking temperatures have also
caused several major tourist attractions
to shut down on the continent with some
needing medical attention under the
sweltering Sun medical attention was
also needed for Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu today after an
apparent bout with dehydration the
Israeli leader later issued a video
statement saying he was in good
condition but urged Israelis to stay out
of the Sun and to drink water
in Winnipeg a determined group of
protesters remains defiant in the face
of a court order to stop blocking the
entrance of a city landfill the group
has been obstructing the main road into
the Brady Road Landfill for more than a
week they are pushing to have a nearby
landfill searched for the remains of two
murdered indigenous women the Manitoba
government has said doing so would be
too risky for workers
now while the injunction to clear the
roadway went into effect Friday evening
so far police have not moved in to
enforce the court order our microlay is
in Winnipeg with the latest
nine days in The Brady Landfill protest
is looking like a stalemate the handful
of protesters still there have traded
barriers for a campfire
last night police liaison officers
handed out copies of a court injunction
requiring them to step aside the request
is that you comply with the order and
then you move to the side of the road
okay yep it didn't take long for the
protesters to give their answer
with the injunction deadline passed this
has very much turned into a waiting and
watching game the media and watching the
protesters protesters watching the media
it all involved are waiting and watching
for the police to show up until and if
that happens they wait and hope for an
end to this politically charged standoff
I'm here every night and I hear the dump
trucks and and it's it's heartbreaking
sound to keep hearing
um and it's just an emotional world of
course just to be here Jeremy skipicky
was charged last December with four
counts of first-degree murder the
remains of one of his alleged victims
Rebecca cantwa was found in The Brady
Landfill and please believe Morgan
Harris and Mercedes Myron are buried in
another landfill north of the city but
when a study found it would cost 184
million dollars to search through the
site while exposing workers to toxic
chemicals the city in Province said it
was too risky prompting a scaling rebuke
from the federal government you know my
reflection on this is that this has been
dealt with in a very heartless way and
now QP which represents over 700 000
workers across Canada has weighed in
suggesting the site be thoroughly
searched and that they are willing to
work with any authorities to provide
support and expertise to any
organization conducting a search so what
to do
taken a toll on winnipeggers some of
whom have openly lashed out undaunted
the protesters continue to expect a
police intervention while hoping
political leaders show up to negotiate
there's no threats here there's no
aggression here there's no violence here
so I don't know I don't understand maybe
they have embarrassing to do but their
presence is not here microwave Global
News Winnipeg
frustrations over the cost of rent in
Toronto was on display in Canada's
largest city residents and supporters of
two buildings in Toronto's West End took
part in What They're calling a rally for
fair rent
now won't stop
tenants have been withholding rent
payments from their corporate landlord
since last month they say rent has
increased three times higher than the
building's rent control guidelines
well we hope a strong message will be
sent to the landlords that tenants have
had enough we need rent control
inflation and the cost of living in the
city combined with the lack of adequate
affordable housing has reached a peak
and people just can't survive with
status quo
the landlord has said the increases are
a result of work done prior to it
acquiring the building and they're
working with the federal government to
increase the number of affordable
housing units offered
they fled the horrors of the Taliban
coming up why Afghan refugees including
children are now being arrested in
Pakistan
ukrainians fleeing Russia's ongoing war
will soon have a new pathway for
permanent residency in Canada
starting in the fall permanent residency
will be extended to ukrainians living in
Canada with temporary status as long as
they have at least one family member
living here more details are expected
before the program launches in October
the announcement from the federal
government comes on the same day in
emergency immigration program was set to
expire and the Canadian government is
concerned about the fate of some of the
thousands of Afghan refugees who are now
living in Pakistan they escaped fearing
arrest and even death at the hands of
the Taliban who now rule Afghanistan but
now Pakistani authorities are
questioning their right to be in that
country leading the Afghan Nationals to
live in fear of arrest and deportation
spoke with some of those refugees in
Islamabad
has been staying inside avoiding the
Pakistani police while she waits for her
sponsorship case to be heard in Canada
anwari was a human rights defender in
Afghanistan after the Taliban took power
she escaped to Pakistan with her family
due to the fear of being detained by the
Taliban but now that fair is back police
of Pakistan arrest my husband it's so
difficult to ask to realize release my
husband
we gave to them money zohal is the
mother of four girls and has a one-year
Visa their estate needs to be extended
every two months at the torchham border
crossing
250 kilometers away Pakistani police
have started to search an arrest Afghan
refugees whose Visa have expired life in
Pakistan is so difficult it's not just
adults even children have been arrested
our result a 17 year old Afghan Refugee
was ecstatic after winning a Jiu-Jitsu
match but had no idea she would soon be
detained
and her coach were detained by the
Pakistani police because their visa had
run out new refugees who came in the
last two years do not receive cards from
unit CR and state they receive unit CR
celebs which are not acceptable to the
Pakistan police
[Music]
she says the police were acting like
they do not know the unit CR and told
her you should get a visa on the new
arrival Pakistan is not supportive of
you know granting them Refugee status we
are trying the best we are doing
advocacy with them more than one million
Afghan refugees are in Pakistan 600 000
are new arrival who are waiting for
their cases they say they are fed up
with the Refuge with attention and
police asking for bribes they claim the
only way that they can get the Pakistani
visas through the black market we send
several emails to the Pakistan
government but have not heard back the
Canadian government has pledged to bring
at least 40 000 Afghan Nationals to
Canada
by the end of 2023 so far more than 33
400 Afghan refugees Now call Canada home
zohal is hoping her family will be next
I refreshed from the Canada government
process my case I have small children
Global News
Ottawa
[Music]
the freedom to fix why manufacturers are
making it harder to repair our gadgets
[Music]
whether it's phones or computers you've
likely had a harder time getting your
products repaired these days in a story
originally featured on the new reality
Krista Hesse looks at what some see as a
broken system for maintaining what we
own and the growing movement to fix it
old radio in the 60s
more vintage turntables
I prefer repairing old stuff because I
can actually fix it like it comes in
it's fixed but I got a happy customer
inside the door repair isn't John
Fidel's blood American Electronics is a
family-owned repair shop in Toronto's
West End John's father Frank Fidel
started the business in 1973.
back in the 70s and 80s companies used
to have parts counter deaths
I used to ride my bicycle to these uh
factories and pick up parts for my
father
a lot has
Parts counters have gone by the wayside
and technology has become more
sophisticated and more difficult to
repair but not for the reasons you think
there isn't any reason that the stuff we
have today is harder to fix than stuff
from 20 years ago it's really the system
that has atrophy manufacturers used to
sell parts over the last 20 30 years
they've systematically stopped doing
that hey I'm Kyle with iFixit and we're
going to take some stuff apart today
iFixit was kyleween's Radical response
it's a website that offers everything
most manufacturers won't repair guides
tools and parts more and more these days
we get products from manufacturers and
they don't have a plan for us to be able
to maintain it
that's herding repair shops and fueling
our throwaway culture and it has Grave
implications for the environment and our
wallets Kyle is part of a growing
movement of people pushing back right to
repair is the idea that if you bought it
you should be able to fix it
but even skilled technicians like John
have to go to Great Lengths to do simple
repairs once the product becomes out of
warranty we cannot call the
manufacturers directly we are reference
to a third-party Logistics type
companies just basically warehousing
companies
those companies will sell John an
entirely new circuit board for a couple
hundred dollars
but often he just needs a tiny component
part I've gotten quotes for boards that
are more than three quarters the price
of the product it just it doesn't make
sense
we absolutely can make products that
last longer if we want to right now the
companies are making so much money
selling us a new thousand dollar phone
every two years that they don't really
have an incentive companies argue they
are protecting consumers safety and
privacy by restricting who's able to do
repairs and also that by withholding
repair information in Parts they are
safeguarding their intellectual property
rights
the right to repair is about giving
people more control over the things they
already own with the movement gaining
momentum big tech companies have begun
to make some concessions Apple has
launched a DIY repair program Google and
Samsung now sell parts for their phones
Nokia and Microsoft are making more
repairable products but Advocates say in
order to fix all our devices we need to
repair the entire system it's a
fundamental human right to have access
to the knowledge to how to fix all the
things that we depend on for Modern Life
Krista Hesse Global News Toronto
[Music]
unseated and Unstoppable the unlikely
likely bet she made with her tennis
coach
[Music]
a magical moment at Wimbledon today is
Marketa Von rossova stuns the tennis
world becoming the first unseated player
to win the women's title the unlikely
Czech Champions family was in shock at
the 6464 win including her husband who
got there just in time after originally
staying home to take care of their cat
the coveted trophy was held up by Von
rooseva who was ranked 42 in the world
she beat six seed ons Jabor who was
hoping to become the first Arab and
first African woman to win a grand slam
title
and that sentiment of not being done yet
holds even greater meaning for one man
in Halifax Frank Whiteley suffered a
heart attack last month but as he lay
there dying some quick thinking
bystanders and paramedics took action to
save his life as Global's Vanessa Wright
shows us today Whiteley got a chance to
say thank you
hugs of gratitude from the wife of Frank
Whiteley a Nova scotian man whose life
was saved and what he describes as a
miracle I'm just glad to be alive on the
morning of June 6th Whitely says all he
remembers was walking to work at some
point he went into cardiac arrest and
was unresponsive on a bench on quinnipel
Road in Halifax this was a situation
where the chain of survival pretty much
went textbook perfectly one bystander
call 9-1-1 and began performing CPR and
shortly after another bystander Melissa
Savoy rushed to help until paramedics
arrived I search search search the
Facebook everywhere just to try to see
if he made it through if I could find
anything on him the 59 year old was
revived twice before making it to
hospital and spent two days on life
support
well I really like
escape the bullet twice type thing so as
very very lucky now more than a month
later whiteley's granddaughter arranged
for a reunion between the communications
officer who took the 911 call the
paramedics and one of the bystanders who
helped save his life that day it feels
great I was waiting for this day we're
just waiting for him to be better and be
ready to meet us and it was great
again once we hang up that phone we're
just right on to the next one and it's
it's that's kind of it that's all we get
um so to hear something uh so great
happen and be a part of it it kind of
reminds you why you started the job in
the first place and yeah it's a nice
feeling paramedics say situations like
these are a reminder of the importance
of knowing how to provide basic medical
assistance just knowing hot how to
perform CPR and how to use an AED can
really increase someone's chance
Whiteley says he is recovering well and
is most looking forward to returning to
his normal routine something only made
possible by the help of strangers turned
Heroes Vanessa Wright Global News
Halifax
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm foreign Oster and on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is Grand Prairie Nova Scotia
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
foreign